do you do exercise I know I hate it I do
it because I have to do it doesn't mean
look like a man who works out a lot yes
ones in here though is the one in here
screw the whole thing and I heard it
helps prevent credit cards yeah yeah
yeah yeah this is for you thanks mommy
Wow okay tell her about your workout
yeah what are you doing for fitness
nothing isolating my blood I'm doing a
contest what do you mean I'm sure I
could have the most coagulated blood
where it just doesn't move like it just
yeah III don't exercise I don't um do
anything of a yoga I don't do anything
physical yeah yeah when we move okay
would you rather you know what an
ironman is right it wasn't weight you've
done I've been to sprint Iron Man's won
when I was 12 and the next when I was 19
but never sprint Ironman so there a
shorter way shorter version of so what
walk me through what that is it was
terrible for me my mom forced me into it
because I was a swimmer and she thought
well you know you'll be ahead of the
pack you'll finish first in the swim and
then you can just you know race your way
home and like that the whole racing
thing that's a [ __ ] 4050 mile bike
ride wait wait so walk me through it so
it's it's 40 to 50 mile bike ride so
it's I think it's a fifth it's a mile
swim okay it's a 40 I think it's a 40
kilometer bike ride and then it's a 10k
run which really isn't so bad compared
to the real Iron Men which is what
double that it I think it's like
quadruple desert I can see yeah
that's [ __ ] but I was 12 and one
legged man beat me what my first one I
came in my sister and I she did a relay
so her team won and I came out it was an
international one and her she and I came
out fourth and fifth on the swim I mean
we were jamming we were out of there we
were like whoa
yeah this is a [ __ ] lead and I got on
the bike and I crashed because I didn't
I really wasn't the good I had never
trained to bike I just always biked
around my neighborhood didn't even have
the correct road bike and then I am one
legged man race imagine crashing on your
bike in the run - he didn't beat me on
the bike cause he was special legs made
for him is the run that's me I was so
exhausted I had never trained for when I
was only a swimmer mom my mom was wild I
was her racehorse I can't believe your
mom didn't kill you after the [ __ ]
she did you were my daughter in a
one-legged man I would leave you at the
race and I remember there was on TV
there was a channel called like Star
Sports and they did a little montage of
the Sprint Ironman they were like and
one of the most inspirational finishes
was that of a 12 year old a split screen
with a one-legged eyeball I swear oh
yeah I would I would have been drugs
right that in there and every Sunday on
the local TV saw me with like my I had
my little cornrows because that's how I
would compete in yeah and with braces
and if I can finish you can do it too
every Sunday like [ __ ] public-access
TV we have to find that it was so
embarrassing I'm like oh man beat me how
are you how are you thinking that's even
remotely inspirational Oh
what if a no-legged man beat you on his
body like a worm man wait did he have a
prosthetic eye forget he was one of
those guys that was so famous because he
had just done one of those like 40 40
mile treks across the [ __ ] grant one
of those guys the inspirational guy I
hate those people don't you hate them
why are you - hey
I know I hate like when they don't they
can't they're blind and they can play
the piano right it is it's like listen
you know there's something that you I
don't have eyes and yet I can do this
ten times better than yeah and they're
always grateful they're like well I may
not have the gift of but I can play the
piano by ear my yeah and they have like
location like dolphins have you seen
that guy that blind guy he just looked
and it bounces back on him so he can
drive and bicycle Hawaiian I swear he
was on Oprah yeah yes eco cuz you know
like in beluga whales and dolphins like
these ocean mammals they have this thing
called a melon and it's it's it's for
echolocation I find him please yeah we
will he drives blinding I know he
doesn't he bicycles blind if I see a
movie like that I root against him like
in my left foot when he's painting with
I want to chop my friends I want I can
see it cuz it's a goddamn bummer and I
don't want to be bummed it's a bummer
but it's an inspirational bummer it's
but you know what know why people love
these [ __ ] let me just say the guy
that has AIDS and then he goes and cures
cancer I can't do in my heart is to it I
know I'll tell you why my left foot no
just listen
yeah yeah is is that it's not the [ __ ]
the story okay it's where you first go
oh that's the greatest actor of all time
dis Daniel day-lewis Yeah right so then
you watch it because of his performance
he's so good in that movie yeah cuz you
didn't know who he was before that right
right this is before last Mohicans when
he was a star so here's this young actor
he had been in he was in Gandhi
seen him a couple of things but like you
know supporting roles but he you
literally thought number one it was what
what diseases he have cerebral palsy
right so you think what he has cerebral
palsy you know they found a cerebral
palsy actor but then when you turns out
it's just a regular dude right he's
doing it he's doing it it's pretty
mind-blowing to me I hate yes go ahead I
never that never resonate Rudy I never
saw that
I never that's a white bummer to isn't
that everyone loves it except for me cuz
I [ __ ] Rudy
now he's just short is that what he
thought what that is about well he's a
Visa short um not very athletic
persistent kid who wanted to play
football for Notre Dame and so he just
did everything he could to finally be
allowed to play one game how annoying
and how annoying and that he ruined the
team like did he not oh yes fire the
like here's what it in rocky for
instance you know when Ivan Drago
yes Hills Apollo Creed Apollo 3 yeah
yeah you you in the rocky trains to beat
this guy that's unbeatable
yeah there's suspense I like the Rocky
movies I do right he goes into a log
cabin in the snow yes [ __ ] rain
cooling [ __ ] right right and at the end
of the movie he overcomes this
impossible task yeah and it becomes a
winner in Rudy okay here's a guy we see
his journey yeah he plays the last ten
seconds of a football game okay that's
the ending and then they chant Rudy Rudy
he doesn't do anything special okay but
but he does inspire his team who gives a
[ __ ] man yeah I mean he was never as
make a movie called Joey the guy the
captain of the team
yeah yeah [ __ ] because in every movie
there is Rudy but we don't see them in
the movie you know why they're
unimportant in every book if you see
even Mission Impossible
there are CIA agents there aren't good
right but you're saying Rudy should have
been the mascot yeah but here's the
difference between being an underdog and
just being straight-up unqualified like
you can be an underdog and work your way
to a point of being a success in that
team he wasn't that they just passed the
ball to him once and he played ten
minutes it's just so his dad could be
happy that and say his son was on the
football roster like you were never
supposed to even be here a lot of people
just were nice about it yeah he kind of
bullied his way in it sounds like yeah
like if it was a chick thing right like
I imagined myself cuz I was an athlete
if there were girls like that we're
never as good hmm but somehow thought
that they were supposed to be and their
Idol that entitles I agree no dude I
have real athleticism
[Music]